how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
all things mcu now i know i don't
normally post on sundays even though i
did last sunday but it's another
saturday night where we get some awesome
news about the marvel cinematic universe
spider-man 3 is shaping up to be quite
an amazing movie
spider-man far from home already left us
with a massive
cliffhanger wondering what is going to
happen in spider-man 3.
peter parker's identity has been
revealed everybody knows that he's
spider-man now but
recently some major bombs have been
dropped over the past week and a half
it's been confirmed that jamie foxx's
electro from the amazing spider-man 2
a spider-man film that doesn't even
exist within the mcu
is going to be in spider-man 3 that is
in the mcu
and then of course the huge news that
doctor strange is going to be in
spider-man 3 and will be peter's
mentor and then of course there's the
whole possibility that the multiverse
could just be
blown up we could see andrew garfield
spider-man and toby maguire spider-man
as well
and there's one person that we've been
missing a rumor for but today
we have it and that person or persons or
person and alien
are venom and eddie brock everybody's
been wanting the venom and spider-man
crossover for a very long time now ever
since we got tom hardy as eddie brock
and tom holland as spider-man
well today we have a report from daniel
richmond about venom and spider-man 3.
according to his report he says there is
a general interest
from the studios for tom hardy's venom
to show up in spider-man 3.
it's unclear right now if the interest
is from sony
marvel or both he says there have been
no real talks yet and hardy's
involvement would presumably be for just
a cameo role
and this is pretty much what you would
want if venom was indeed in spider-man
3.
there's already so much going on in
spider-man 3 and there's already so many
characters going to be in the film if
venom showed up it would be pretty
convoluted and pretty crowded
venom and spider-man wouldn't get the
one-on-one time that we would want them
to have
but venom making a quick cameo in
spider-man 3 would be the perfect
opportunity to
officially combine the sony pictures
universe of
marvel characters or the sp umc as they
call it and the marvel cinematic
universe or the mcu
not only would this be the studios
telling us in a very official way
hey these two universes are crossing
over and do exist
within each other but venom and
spider-man 3 would
set up either a venom 3 spider-man vs
venom or just another movie that
involves spider-man and venom when it
can be
all about them and this may be their
plan because we don't know if spider-man
is going to be
in venom 2 or not we've definitely heard
rumors but nothing is confirmed at this
point
but right now thanks to this report we
do know that the studios are interested
in having venom make a quick cameo in
spider-man 3.
let's hope it happens so the future can
get set up to see a
real venom vs spider-man face-off so let
me know what you think about this news
in the comments down below would you
like venom to make an appearance in
spider-man 3
and if you do want to see him appear do
you want it to be a quick cameo or to
play some significant
role let me know what you think in the
comments down below and be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news
don't forget to give the video a like
for a live update you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof